why aren you decisions
quicker these two people have very
different views to reach a shared goal
they need to listen to each other and
find common
ground this is also exactly what makes
European democracy work so members of
the European Parliament your elected
representatives debate argue disagree
agree negotiate to shape EU laws the
same process happens in and between
different EU
institutions getting 27 nationalities
and multiple political voices to hear
each other out takes
time having a space like the European
Parliament where diverse ideas and
beliefs are constructively challenged is
vital to keeping healthy debate and
democracy
alive